some centers under the previous order at
12 noon the Senate will receive the
managers of the House of Representatives
to exhibit the articles of impeachment
against Donald John Trump President of
the United States the hour of 12:00 noon
having arrived and a quorum being
present the sergeant at arms will
present the managers on the part of the
House of Representatives mr. president
and members of the announced the
presence of the managers on the part of
the House of Representatives to conduct
proceedings on behalf of the House
concerning the impeachment of Donald
John Trump President of the United
States on the part of the house will be
received and escorted to the well of the
Senate
the the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the House
of Representative the the sergeant at
arms will make the proclamation hear ye
hear ye hear ye all persons are
commanded to keep silent on pain of
imprisonment while the House of
Representative mr. president the
managers on the part of the House of
Representatives are present and ready to
present the articles of impeachment
which have been preferred by the House
of Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States the
house adopted the following resolution
which were the permission of the Senate
I will read House Resolution 798
appointing and authorizing managers for
the impeachment trial of Donald John
Trump President of the United States
resolved that mr. Schiff mr. Nadler ms
Lofgren mr. Jeffrey's ms Demmings
mr. crow and miss Garcia of Texas are
appointed managers to conduct the
impeachment trial against Donald John
Trump President of the United States
that a message be sent to the Senate to
inform the Senate of these appointments
and that the managers so appointed may
in connection with the preparation and
conduct of the trial exhibit articles of
impeachment to the Senate and take all
other actions necessary which may
include the following employing legal
clerical and other necessary assistance
and incurring such other expenses as may
be necessary to be paid for amounts
available to the committee on the
judiciary under applicable expense
resolutions or from the applicable
account of the House of Representatives
number two sending for persons and
papers and filing with the Secretary of
the Senate on the part of the House of
Representatives any pleadings in
conjunction with or subsequent to the
exhibition of the articles of
impeachment that the managers may
consider necessary with the permission
of the Senate I will now read the
articles of impeachment House Resolution
755 House Resolution 755 impeaching
Donald John Trump president of the
United States for high crimes and
misdemeanors resolved that president
that Donald J Trump President of the
United States is impeached for high
crimes and misdemeanors and that the
following articles of impeachment be
exhibited to the United States Senate
articles of impeachment exhibited by the
House of Representatives of the United
States of America in the name of itself
and of the people of the United States
of America against Donald John Trump
president to the United States of
America in maintenance and support of
its impeachment against him for high
crimes and misdemeanors article 1 abuse
of power the Constitution provides that
the House of Representatives shall have
the sole power of impeachment and that
the president shall be removed from
office on impeachment for and conviction
of treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors in his conduct of the
office of the President of the United
States and in violation of his
constitutional oath faithfully to
execute the office of President of the
United States and to the best of his
ability preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States and in
violation of his constitutional duty to
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed Donald J Trump has abused the
powers of the presidency in that using
the powers of his high office President
Trump solicited the interference of a
foreign government Ukraine in the 2020
United States presidential election he
did so through a scheme or course of
conduct that included soliciting the
government of you
crane to publicly announce
investigations that would benefit his
re-election harm the election prospects
of a political opponent and influence
the 2020 United States presidential
election to his advantage President
Trump also sought to pressure the
government of Ukraine to take these
steps by conditioning official United
States government acts of significant
value to Ukraine on its public
announcement of the investigations
president Trump engaged in this scheme
or course of conduct for corrupt
purposes in pursuit of personal
political benefit in so doing President
Trump used the powers of the presidency
in a manner that compromised the
national security of the United States
and undermined the integrity of the
United States democratic process he thus
ignored and injured the interests of the
nation president Trump engaged in this
scheme or course of conduct through the
following means number one President
Trump
acting both directly and through his
agents within and outside the United
States government corruptly solicited
the government of Ukraine to publicly
announce investigations into a a
political opponent former vice president
Joseph R Biden Jr and be a discredited
theory promoted by Russia alleging that
Ukraine rather than Russia interfered in
the 2016 United States presidential
election number two with the same
corrupt motives president Trump acting
both directly and through his agents
within and outside the United States
government condition two official acts
on the public announcement that he had
requested a the release of 390 million
91 million dollars of United States
taxpayer funds that Congress had
appropriated on a bipartisan basis for
the purpose of providing vital military
and security assistance to Ukraine to
oppose
Russian aggression and which President
Trump had ordered suspended and be a
head of state meeting at the White House
which the president of Ukraine sought to
demonstrate continued United States
support for the government of Ukraine in
the face of Russian aggression number
three faced with the public revelation
of his actions president Trump
ultimately released the military and
security assistance to the government of
Ukraine but has persisted in openly and
corruptly urging and soliciting Ukraine
to undertake investigations for his
personal political benefit these actions
were consistent with president Trump's
previous invitations of foreign
interference in United States elections
in all of this president Trump abused
the powers of the presidency by ignoring
and injuring national security and other
vital national interests to obtain an
improper personal political benefit he
has also betrayed the nation by abusing
his high office to enlist a foreign
power in corrupting democratic elections
where for president Trump by such
conduct has demonstrated that he will
remain a threat to national security and
the Constitution if allowed to remain in
office and has acted in a manner grossly
incompatible with self governance and
the rule of law president Trump thus
warrants impeachment and trial removal
from office and disqualification to hold
and enjoy any office of Honor trust or
profit under the United States article
to obstruction of Congress the
Constitution provides that the House of
Representatives shall have the sole
power of impeachment and that the
president shall be removed from office
on impeachment for and conviction of
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors in his conduct of the
office of President of the United States
and in violation of his constitutional
oath faithfully to execute the office of
President of the United States and to
the best of his ability preserve protect
and defend the Constitution of the
United States and in violation of his
constitutional duty to take care that
the laws be faithfully executed Donald J
Trump has directed the unprecedented
categorical and indiscriminate defiance
of subpoenas issued by the House of
Representatives pursuant to its sole
power of impeachment President Trump has
abused the power of the presidency in a
manner offensive to and subversive of
the Constitution in that the House of
Representatives has engaged in an
impeachment inquiry focused on president
Trump's corrupt solicitation of the
government of Ukraine to interfere in
the 2020 United States presidential
election as part of this impeachment
inquiry the committee's undertaking the
investigation served subpoenas seeking
documents and testimony deemed vital to
the inquiry from various executive
branch agencies and offices and current
and former officials in response without
lawful cause or excuse president Trump
directed executive branch agencies
offices and officials not to comply with
those subpoenas president Trump thus
interposed the powers of the presidency
against the lawful subpoenas of the
House of Representatives and assumed to
himself functions and judgments
necessary to exercise the sole power of
impeachment vested by the Constitution
in the House of Representatives
president Trump abused the powers of his
high office through the following means
number one directing the White House to
defy a lawful subpoena by withholding
the production of documents sought
therein by the committee's number two
directing other executive branch
agencies and offices to defy lawful
subpoenas and withhold the production of
documents and records from the capito
from the committee's in response to
which the Department of State the Office
of Management and Budget Department of
Energy
and Department of Defense refused to
produce a single document or record
directing current and former number
three directing current and former
executive branch officials not to
cooperate with the committee's in
response to which nine administration
officials defied subpoenas for testimony
namely John Michael Mick Mulvaney Robert
B Blair John a Eisenberg Michael Ellis
Preston Wells Griffith Russell T watt
Michael Duffy Bryan McCormack and T
Ulrich Bret bull these actions were
consistent with president Trump's
previous efforts to undermine United
States government investigations into
foreign interference in United States
elections through these actions
president Trump sought to arrogate to
himself the right to determine the
propriety scope and nature of the
impeachment inquiry into his own conduct
as well as the unilateral prerogative to
deny any and all information to the
House of Representatives in the exercise
of its sole power of impeachment in the
history of the Republic no president has
ever ordered the complete defiance of an
impeachment inquiry or sought to
obstruct and impede so comprehensively
the ability of the House of
Representatives to investigate high
crimes and misdemeanors this abuse of
office served to cover up the
president's own repeated misconduct and
to seize and control the power of
impeachment and thus to nullify a vital
constitutional safeguard vested solely
in the House of Representatives in all
of this president Trump acted in a
manner contrary to his trust as
president and subversive of
constitutional government to the great
prejudice of the cause of law and
justice and to the manifest injury of
the people of the United States
we're for president Trump by such
conduct as demonstrated that he will
remain a threat to dn't and subversive
of constitutional government to the
great prejudice of the cause of law and
justice and to the manifest injury of
the people of the United States
wherefore President Trump by such
conduct has demonstrated that he will
remain a threat to the mr. president
that completes the exhibition of the
articles of impeachment against Donald
John Trump President of the United
States the manager's request that the
Senate take order for the trial the
managers now requests leave to withdraw
thank you mister shift the Senate will
duly notify the house were represented
when it is ready to proceed to trial
mr. project majority leader but the
information
not over the trial is required in
article 1 section 3 Clause 6 of the
United States Constitution also under
the previous order the presiding officer
has been authorized to appoint a
committee of four senators - upon the
recommendation of the majority leader
and - upon the recommendation of the
Democratic leader to escort the Chief
Justice and to the Senate chamber I ask
that the presiding officer do so now the
chair pursuant to order January 15 2020
on behalf of the majority leader and the
Democratic leader appoints mr. Blunt of
Missouri mr. Leahy of Vermont mr. Graham
of South Carolina and mrs. Feinstein of
California to escort the Chief Justice
of the United States into the Senate
chamber so for the further information
of senators there will be a live quorum
call prior to the arrival of the Chief
Justice at 2:00 p.m. today I ask
unanimous consent that the Senate stand
in recess subject to the call of the
truth
without objection the Senate stands in
recess subject to the call of the chair
I understand like no one from us yet
they these kind of conditions before we
are used to pollution like we play in
China we play in more polluted countries
but I mean this is smoky something
different that for sure we are not used
to it
and I think I mean citizens and everyone
was advised to stay inside and I'm we
didn't expect that we will be playing
yesterday so it was a bit shocking I
found it a good reason to paint in Hong
Kong to give gift to the Hong Kong
people to encourage them in their
struggle which reminds me even to the
West and East struggle